I hit a $100 million net worth at age 31
but before that I lost all my money
twice and the difference between me
losing all my money the first few times
and now are these rules so this is nobs
advice for making money and keeping it
number one passive income is a lie if
you think about how money is made you
make money during time because every
minute we're alive a minute passes time
passes and we make money over that time
period which means every single person
on planet Earth has a dollars per hour
that they make and so it's not that
passive income doesn't exist just as
much as active income doesn't exist it's
a spectrum where it's how active is it
or how passive is the activity that I'm
doing relative to the time that I'm
investing and so I would eliminate
active versus passive and simply say
what is my return on time or how much do
I make per hour it's just that most
people get really scared of that like no
one should trade their hours for money
everyone trades their hours for money
it's just that when they receive the
money it's just not denoted in hours and
so I think there's two Downstream
impacts in terms of changing your
behavior around this that I had to apply
number one is that I was obsessed with
trying to find quick easy low you know
effort money things and so I ended up
spending tons of money on things that I
was obsessed with hoping would cost me
no time to make and I would put not
nearly enough time to the things I was
acting ly making money with and thinking
how could I just make my active income
significantly higher and I would get
obsessed with the idea that everything I
did actively had to be scalable or it
wasn't worth it because if it's not
scalable then why why should I buy I
shouldn't trade my time for money but if
I looked at what I was making over the
last year and divided it by the amount
of money I made per hour this activity
was 15 times what I was averaging per
hour so I should absolutely do as many
hours of that until all of my hours are
that and then I should find something
else I can trade my time for that's even
higher and so if you want a very
humbling experience look at how much you
made last year and then divide it by
2,000 if you want to know how much you
made just in a 40-hour work week now if
you want to look at how much you made
per actual hour of being alive you can
divide it by around 8,000 or just take
that number and divide it by four and
that's actually how much you make per
hour and so when you're looking at is
this worth my time if it's more than
that number it probably is and so what I
should have done and what changed for me
was that I stopped trying to invest my
money from my active into trying to find
more passive things and try to say how
do I invest my money more into my active
to multiply my active that I know is
working number two if you can't buy it
twice don't buy it once or even buy it
three times or four times or five times
over don't buy it once and the way that
really shifted how I started spending
money or rather started saving money and
not spending money was when I started
looking at how much time it took me to
make the amount of money post tax to buy
whatever I wanted and I remember this
clear as day I was working at Smoothie
King as a blender tender and I was
making 675 an hour and I had just gotten
a raise from 625 an hour uh I'm dating
myself anyways and while I was there the
cooworker that I had and I would always
go to lunch next door at Coy which was
like a sandwich shop and it was like 13
bucks for a sandwich right and a drink
and chips and whatever right and so I
remember looking at my check and my 675
an hour after taxes and fees was like
six bucks an hour and I was like man I
gave up 2 hours of my 6-hour shift every
shift to go by lunch and I was like I'm
literally giving a third of my earning
away for lunch every single day if I
knew that I had to work the first two
hours just to get the sandwich I don't
think I'd ever make that trade and yet I
was making it every day and then I
started thinking I'd go to the mall and
like oh do you want a new shirt and it
was at the Gap and it was 30 bucks and I
was like okay well shoot that's a whole
shift and I was like would I work a
whole shift if someone just held up a
shirt that I didn't need to do it and I
was like I don't think I would and so
all of a sudden it started shifting how
my buying happen because I I started
feeling the pain associated with what it
would take if I had to do do that before
getting the thing I was going to buy and
it it completely changed my buying
behavior and to be very clear saving
money won't make you money but saving
money allows you to have money and
having money allows you to look further
out and when you look further out you
can take on bigger risks which
absolutely will make you more money and
when you're looking at the price of
whatever the thing you're trying to buy
is obviously when I was a teenager
looking at a shirt I was looking at okay
I'm making six bucks an hour a shirt's
30 bucks but when you're adult and
you're making $100 an hour and you're
looking at a $500 or ,000 purchase would
you work two days in order to do that I
don't know would I probably not and
sometimes you think hey is uh would I
work all day for two days to go out with
the boys for three hours on Saturday I
I'd probably be like guys I'm I I'm not
going to work for two days just to go
have three hours of fun right that feel
like I'd rather just not work the two
days and that was the thing is whenever
I had the well I'd rather just not work
than do that thing then I was like I
shouldn't buy that thing for example
when I was poor I only spent cash and so
my easiest way of actually creating a
budget was that I had a personal
training client who paid me $2,000 a
month in cash and so 100% of my money
that came in through the business and
credit cards and everything else is just
what went into my bank account and the
only thing I knew I could live on was
was was inside of my wallet and so as
that got replenished and the thing is is
that I'm so scared with money or I was
so Frugal with money that I would always
make sure that I had more than that to
make it for the next payment cuz
sometimes the guy would take a day or
two you pay on Wednesday rather than a
Monday or whatever and I need to make
sure that I had food forb life three
most people overestimate what they can
accomplish in a year and they
underestimate what they can accomplish
in a decade and every new employee that
I have at walks into acquisition. comom
the number one thing that they say they
want is growth and I have this talk with
them which is the 10year million doll
contract but it's less about the million
dollars and more about take whatever
your net worth is now and add a zero to
it or add two zeros to it you can
accomplish that in a decade if you look
at the biggest companies in the entire
world who were worth multiple billions
from their Inception until the time they
were worth multiple billions many times
it's under 10 years but it's still more
than five more than seven and so you can
accomplish lifechanging crazy amounts of
wealth in a decade and so if you could
write a contract to yourself and say I
will make no money for 10 years but on
the 10th year I will add a zero or two
zeros or three zeros to my net worth
would you do it and if the answer is yes
which it almost invariably is with every
person who comes into my business then I
say great now act like it and so if you
knew that you would make this amount of
money over that period of time you would
stop this Obsession myself included this
is me giving my advice to my S who lost
it twice when I was able to shift to
okay what would I have to do that would
make it unreasonable that I don't 10x in
10 years then all of a sudden I started
making very reasonable bets that I knew
would compound unto itself over that
period of time and then winning became
inevitable rather than a game of chance
and so often times you have potential
earning and then actualized earning and
usually as you're realizing the
potential earning you have you're
usually losing out on your investing
into that potential right you're
realizing the potential and that's kind
of like the kid that learns one skill
and then immediately says I'm going to
start a business opportunity around this
one skill that makes me $5,000 a month
or they have this one skill and say hey
this this company is willing to pay me
$100,000 a year to go do this skill
where I have this other company that
will give me a free internship where I
could 10x my potential earning in three
years but I'm going to make $35,000 a
year for the three years which one would
you take the problem is most people will
take the $100,000 now and forgo the
investment itself and that's the thing
is we the asset that we invest in and
the currency we invest into ourselves in
is time experience and skills right
skill is the outcome the time and the
effort is what we put into it to gain
the experiences which ultimately give us
the skills but if you're in an
environment where you're not compounding
your potential earning then you're
actually losing out long-term you're
ripping up your million doll or your 10x
or 100x contract for a decade from now
so you can get the short fast money
today and that's why in the early days
when you have limited amounts of money
but put lots of time and energy instead
of putting your money in the S&P 500 I
like to say put in the 500 because the
asset that is you will always beat the
stock market number four you should only
have to get rich once in other words
don't bet what you have and need for
something you don't have and don't need
and some of the gravest mistakes I made
manifested in for example me getting
into a partnership that I shouldn't have
gotten into because I want it even more
faster now when you get into a
partnership which is usually the time
where you put the most risk on the table
one is you guarantee the largest
decrease in your earning power you pay
what the most expensive thing you have
which is equity to somebody else and so
people get obsessive about what they're
they're you know 5% 10% later when we're
making money but day one they're like
all right we cut the pie in half oh we
cut the pie into thirds right up front
before anything's really happen if you
work with a partner or decide to partner
up with somebody one of your friends one
of your co-workers this is coming from
somebody who has nine failed
Partnerships before I met Lea and then
that has now worked and now I have
successful Partnerships a partner needs
to have one of these three things that
you do not have either have to have
money that you don't have and then the
clear contribution is that money they
need to have experience you don't have
and the clear contribution is that
experience or number three they have
time and energy that you don't have and
the clear contribution is that time and
energy and so I added that second part
on is that just because someone has it
experience if they're not contributing
it to the partnership clearly then
you're still not going to get the
benefit from it if they have the time
and the energy but it's not clearly
defined how they're going to invest that
time and energy into the things you both
get a return then it's not going to be a
good partnership and I've lost so much
money in Partnerships especially early
on one of my two big losses was from a
partner and a big part of it was I was
insecure and I thought I just had to
have somebody else cuz I was afraid to
do it on my own real quick if you're
trying to make your first dollar online
you can go to school.com games we've got
a whole system that's set up it's a
platform you can start it for free I've
got instructional videos I take a call
every single week and so if you do do
that you can hop on the call on Monday
and I'll say hi to you just let me know
that you're brand new if you are a
business owner and you're trying to
scale and you're doing a million bucks a
year and you want to go bigger go to
acquisition. comom hit scale and uh we'd
love to see if we could help you out at
one of the workshops we run here in
Vegas which brings me number five if you
never learn to manage your time you're
never going to learn to manage your
money and so the thing is is that all of
us obviously have equal amounts of time
that we're given not necessarily in life
but at least every day and so the people
who get the best Returns on their money
are the ones who learn how to best
invest their time and so a big
misconception around money is that money
in my opinion is an encapsulated version
of time and since all of us trade time
for the money that we get then it means
for each person money represents a
certain amount of time and the wealthier
you get it's just that the denomination
of money represents less time for you
and so for someone else $100 may
represent 4 hours for a wealthier person
$100 may represent 4 minutes and so it's
a constant appraisal that you do on a
regular basis looking on your calendar
and saying what things do I have here
that I could trade my time for for more
money and so again this video is about
making money overall I'm not saying that
you can't spend time with your girl but
there is a transaction cost for that
time and as long as you're willing to
make the the trade then trade it all day
but the bad trades are the one that when
you actually think about it in terms of
what it costs you'd say I wouldn't do
the trade that's a bad deal and so over
time if you continue to trade up how
much time you invest for what it makes
you you will always make more in your
income year after year after year number
six check your bank account before you
check social media first thing in the
morning and if it hurts you to check
your bank account first thing then you
need to do it even more because for me I
started not knowing where my money was
going and so I had a friend who was like
dude just look and I honestly had
anxiety looking in my bank account
looking at what money was going out and
all that kind of stuff and so I started
making that habit and I had to confront
it but the crazy thing is is as I
started looking at my money as I started
paying attention to my money my money
started paying attention to me and
hanging around and so Peter drer said
what gets measured gets managed and so
one of the most fascinating things that
I found with human behavior in any kind
of change is that the first thing that
you can do to improve any metric for any
skill is to actually measure it and so
if you want to lose weight if you weigh
yourself every day no how matter how
painful the number is that intervention
alone helps people lose weight you don't
even have to talk about diet you don't
have to tell someone to exercise if they
look at the scale every day they become
aware of it and when you become aware of
a problem you start consciously or
subconsciously making moves to change it
you have that hesitation before you put
that food in your mouth you have that
hesitation before you take your wallet
out when you're looking at your bank
account every day it doesn't matter what
it is whatever you're trying to improve
but look at it confront reality and then
reality will start to improve and if
you're curious how long do you still
check your bank account every day and I
the honest truth is I stopped checking
when we had about 20 million bucks um
and so that started when I had in the
hundreds to thousand dolls uh and
continue to check every day and when I
stopped checking it was that I realized
my daily fluctuations in in Market
movements and things like that across my
assets uh it like I didn't I I basically
wasn't able to really see it on a daily
basis so I had to start extending my
time Horizon for when I would check it
so it' be monthly or quarterly that I
started checking it uh because that way
at least I know I should have some
movement upwards and that is something
that if you've done checking your bank
account every single day four years you
start to already have developed some of
those disciplined skills which then you
can delay gratification of having saved
money for a day to having saved money
for a quarter number seven learn how to
make money before you start trying to
learn how to make money make money so I
see so many guys especially young guys
who are like I've got a th000 bucks how
do I invest $1,000 they're trying to
figure out a way to get that $1,000 to
compound they put it into a compounding
calculator and they're like man if I get
50% returns for the next 40 years I'm
going to be a billionaire but the thing
is is that one it's most likely that
you're going to buy a [__] Dogecoin
and then it's going to tank and then
you're just going to lose your ,000 and
be like wow think about this I just
worked for two weeks or one month to
save that ,000 and I lost it in seconds
so alternatively if you take that $1,000
and you put it into how do I make more
money how do I actively improve the
actions and skills that I have that will
get you far more and that is where you
invest time rather than how do I make
money make money cuz let's be real you
don't have much so take the money you
have into the skill the flow of making
more money rather than trying to take
this tiny thing and going from a 10%
return to a 20% return because the
hundred bucks extra that you yield on
that ,000 I promise you if you learn how
to add 50% to your skill set it'll take
whatever your annual earning is up by
50% and that's going to be a hell of a
lot more than 10 and that's assuming
everything goes up this year which one
out of four years it doesn't when you
say you don't have time just immediately
think to yourself I'm lying this is
[__] because every single person has
between 5 to 9:00 a.m. and 5: to 9:00
p.m. every day of the week even if you
have a 40-hour job even if you're a
full-time student because everybody has
those eight hours per day now the thing
is is that we're not willing to make the
trade-offs because we have these things
that make us comfortable cool if you
reframe that thing as the thing that
makes me comfortable today is the thing
that's going to make me uncomfortable
for a decade all of a sudden the cost of
that Comfort goes up and so then it
flips to if I can become uncomfortable
for to day I can be comfortable for
decades and so then you can seek out
those eight hours and say you know what
I'm going to flip this thing and here's
the crazy part about work work makes you
money in two ways one you work and you
make money and secondly when you're
working you're not spending money and so
when you're starting out you literally
have a double effect the the money that
you're making the whole way through is
stacking up because there's no drains on
it either and so one of the biggest
advantages you have is that you stay
busy one of the keys to investing is
patience what is patience patience is
figuring out activities to do in the
meantime think about it for a second
unpack that patience is figuring out
what to do in the meantime so then if
the goal is to get rich and we know that
that takes time and it takes time for
money to compound and grow then what you
do in the meantime is that you work so
that you have even more money to invest
and that money has the time to invest in
compound while you're working and I am
so passionate about this because this
isn't something that I didn't do right
like when I had my job in the beginning
I just wasn't really taking the time
that I should have and then I was like
you know what I don't want to do this
thing forever I got to get ahead but I
couldn't stop doing my job so I started
spending my mornings and my evenings
every day and both weekend days working
on what I was going to do next and in
the beginning that was studying for the
GMAT cuz I thought business school was
going to be the next move but after
studying for the GMAT and crushing the
test I came to another realization which
was I'm going to go to business school
cuz I want to start a business well you
know what it's going to cost me less
than two years and
$180,000 plus what I didn't make during
the two years of not working I could
probably net $10,000 a year of income
which is what the average business
school person graduated with when I was
looking at business school and I was
like I think I could get to 10 grand a
month if I had 2 years to work and
didn't spend 180 Grand and I took that
money and just put it into a business
now you're like well you didn't even
have 180 Grand you're damn right I
didn't I was able to save up 50 and I
was like I think with this 50 I'll be
able to spend it to learn enough to make
10 grand a month and that's what I did
nine if you don't know how you can lose
money in something then you're going to
lose it think about this for a second if
something looks amazing and you're like
dude there's no way I can lose money on
this you're absolutely going to lose
your ass because of how little you
actually know and so you have to figure
out one what is my downside and all the
different ways that downside can occur
and then attach a reasonable likelihood
that that happens and then probably
multiply it by three because whenever
you have your rosecolor glasses on
you're an entrepreneur or you want to be
an entrepreneur one of the
quintessential traits of
Entrepreneurship is optimism we are
optimists we think it's all going to
work out and you have to have that level
of optimism to start but when you start
you can't continue to have that optimism
around every other opportunity because
then you are going to lose your ass
because you're going to be split between
multiple things and so if you don't know
how you can lose money you absolutely
will because it just is an index of how
little you know 10 the biggest cost that
you have is ignorance so every single
month you've got your rent you've got
your food you've got your clothes you
got your car you got whatever else you
spend and you think that's my fixed
costs years ago I was sitting in the
audience and I saw a man write a million
dollars on a whiteboard and he called
someone from the audience he said how
much do you make per year and they said
$50,000 a year and he said would you
like to make a million dollar a year and
the person said yes and then he put a
minus sign he said did you know that
it's costing you $950,000 per year to
not know how to make a million dollars a
year and it was such a light bulb moment
for me that I realized that the cost of
ignorance is the difference between what
your goals are and what you have today
because if you knew how to achieve your
goals the difference is the value of
that education and conversely the
difference is the cost of that debt debt
of ignorance and so the number one
priority in my life has always been to
pay down ignorance as fast as I possibly
could using whatever currency I needed
to so if that was relational Capital
that means using my network or doing
favors for people or paying money which
is the least efficient way of doing it I
would try and find a way that I could
pay down ignorance to achieve the things
that I wanted so I could get the
information so I could get the learning
when I started um I paid to get into
room so I paid $25,000 $35,000 and
you're like wait I don't have that right
now I get it well you pay $110,000 was
the first thing I ever bought that was
information based that's what I was the
first thing I ever invested and how was
I able to do that because I had save for
two years and I'd save 50 Grand up and
so for me I was like okay this is the
direction I'm going in I'm going to
invest in learning and when I got in
that room the first room I was in was a
gym owner room and I didn't have a gym
and I paid to be in that room so I could
start the gym the right way when I paid
to the $25,000 room it was an internet
marketing room and guess what I didn't
have an internet marketing business but
I paid there so I could try and learn
how to do it the right way rather than
try and start at the wrong way and have
to fix it and so I think a lot of people
wait too long to try and learn I always
want to grab my future and pull it
towards me and so I was willing to spend
as much money as I had available to me
to make those bets because it was a bet
on me and I knew I would never lose that
you can't lose you you always have
Diamond hands on you like till the day
you die you've got you and so the thing
is about investing in education is that
sometimes the lessons you learn aren't
the lessons you expect to learn but you
learn them nonetheless and so sometimes
you go into an education thing and you
don't get what you thought but you still
get something and it was still more than
what you paid and so when I went into
those rooms I'd already used up all my
money to get in the room so I was like
okay what else do I have and so at the
time I knew how to sell and so I just
went to every single person in the room
and was like can I help you sell stuff
and so they'd be like well sure my sales
team sucks or sure my my script sucks or
sure my offer sucks or I don't know how
to overcome these objections and so I
would spend an hour two hours three
hours on the phone with these people
training their teams writing scripts and
they were like dude thanks so much this
is wait I can't can't believe you did
all this and the thing is is that if
you're going to pay for help from
someone pay in
full don't half ass a free gift and so
if you're good at something you're good
at a skill you're an accountant you
don't do one page of someone's taxes if
you're going to do a favor you do the
whole thing you treat them like they're
a paying customer and then they will
respond as though you have paid them and
so it will be like you've given them
money and then you will get that
reciprocity and at the time when I did
those favors all those people I didn't
know what I was going to ask for I just
knew that I would need someone's help in
the room and I'd rather have more phone
numbers I could call for help that owed
me one than none and when I wanted to
make a webinar I called one of the
people who's good at webinars when I
wanted to run ads I called the guy who's
really good at running ads when I wanted
to uh figure out funnels and landing
pages stuff I called the guy who was
really good at funnels and landing pages
CU each of those guys wasn't good at
what I was good at and so we are able to
barter which by the way still to this
day is the most efficient form of trade
because Uncle Sam don't take any piece
of it for us or them everybody wins 11
there's two types of things that you can
learn and so if you're trying to pay
down ignorance you got to know what
you're buying so you can learn about
something something that exists that you
didn't know existed and then you can
learn how to do something and so one is
called declarative knowledge knowledge
of existence the other is called
procedural knowledge which is knowing
how to do it and so if I explain to you
that private Equity exists and this is
how you can buy package and sell a
business for a lot of money now you know
about it which is a prerequisite for
learning how to do it and so when you
buy into access to networks to people to
relationships the primary thing that
you're learning is learning about things
that exist they're going to tell you Tax
Strategies investment strategy marketing
strategy sales strategies business
models that you haven't heard of that is
what you learn there but if they tell
you those things you leave and you get
excited but then you're like well shoot
how do I do it which is the second thing
that you learn how to do which is the
how part and so when you're going into
any kind of investment whether you're
investing time you're investing trade
you're doing some work for someone so
they do work for you back or you're
investing money you better be sure what
you're buying and the interesting thing
about those two types of knowledge is
that the declarative knowledge tends to
teach you things that you didn't know
existed it's the unknown unknowns that
is why some of these are the biggest
breakthroughs when you get into those
rooms with someone making 10 or 100
times more than you they see the world
in a different way whereas when you go
for how to it's more predictable what
you're going to get because you're
specifically trying to learn how the
skills you know it exists and you just
need to clarify the steps to getting
there and so just delineating what
you're trying to learn will help you
actually learn it so the first time I
learned declarative knowledge was that
Facebook ads existed that was in 2013
and so I learned how they how they
worked and I learned just enough to make
them work so I learned declarative
knowledge that they existed and I
learned how to do them in one weekend
super valuable now I was able to ride
that skill set for a couple years until
I was like you know what I need to learn
how to do this at a bigger scale I
wanted to go National with started gym
launch do the turnarounds and so I was
like I need somebody because I had only
run local ads which by the way are much
easier than National style ads and so I
tried to go all around asking people for
help and at this point i' probably used
up the relational Capital that I had
before so I called a bunch of agencies
all of them said they were going to
charge me too much money that I could
afford and then finally I just asked one
guy hey instead of your monthly rate of
$5,000 a month which I couldn't even
come close to affording at the time I
was like can I just pay you per hour now
of course he said I don't trade my time
for money except of course he works over
time and then he gets money later but
sure anyways he doesn't trade time for
money when I said it's America
everything's got a price and he said you
know what 750 an hour I'll do it and I
was like done now mind you 750 an hour
was still a ton of money for me and so I
showed up like it was Harvard on
steroids for these calls cuz I I would
prep for the call I had my notes out I
recorded it I was like I had two people
in the room be like make sure I don't
miss anything right and so I would go
and I had him first document the process
of what he did to run ads as though he
were me then I had him demonstrate it so
he clicked the buttons so I could see
what he was doing and I had him stop and
explain to me each of the steps so I
could put it into my little checklist
too and then finally I duplicated in
front of him which means document
demonstrate duplicate I then did in
front of him to make sure that I was
doing it right and so once I did it
right and I did it right multiple times
in a row and I didn't need him to to to
correct me while I was doing it that's
when I had mastered the skill it took me
eight sessions so it took me 8 hours and
whatever that is times 7:50 in order to
learn 12 a watch isn't going to replace
work a Rolex isn't going to replace
reality and so what happens a lot of
times when you're coming up is that you
want to get status right you feel
downtrod and feel like no one respects
you and that's normal as a young man
that's what you do you don't have any
status that's what you come into the
world as and you got to go make it and
so the thing that you want to do early
on is get status as fast as possible the
thing is a lot of times you trade
shortterm status at the expense of
longterm and so as somebody who has lots
of young men in my audience and
middle-aged men in my audience you'll
never impress someone who's wealthier
than you with assets you'll only impress
people below you so you have the wrong
target audience because to impress poor
people you outspend them to impress rich
people you outwork them and once I
understood this I was like oh the guys
who are at the top of the game give me
respect because they know I'm a future
one of them because they know when they
were my age they doubled down on the
hustle not the Highlight Reel and that
overspending on status happens at every
level so in the beginning it's a watch
right and a little bit later it might be
a car payment and a little bit later it
might be a really big expensive car
payment and then it might be a really
big condo and then it might be a really
nice house and then it might become a
yacht and then becomes a jet and the
thing is is that you add zeros to it but
again you only impress the people
underneath of you not the people above
you and if you want to impress the
people underneath of You by all means do
it but know that that's what you're
about by time like a rich person buy
stuff like a poor person and so when
you're thinking about time being the
most valuable thing if you've already
dedicated yourself to working and
earning an income and learning the
skills then you just want to pour as
much time into that as you can and so
fundamentally you're buying your time
back your lowc cost time or low income
time so it's prepping food going grocery
shopping cleaning your
house whatever else you do with more
income earning time I remember the first
time I closed a $500 sale at my gym I
realized that that sale took me 30
minutes and I knew that for me to buy
groceries for the whole month four times
would take me $500 and far more than 30
minutes and so I thought to myself my
God if all of that time I was grocery
shopping and and food prepping and and
and and cleaning up after myself and
then doing laundry if all of that time I
could just sell more in a couple hours I
could do all of that stuff for free and
my poor mind was like Hey That's
wasteful you could be doing that stuff
on your own but you buy time like you're
rich you spend money on stuff like
you're poor so buy time not stuff
because when you buy time you can
replace the money you bought it with and
some let me put some real numbers to
this so the average American spends
$1,500 a month on 96 hours of work and
that breaks down roughly to cleaning
their house cleaning their
clothes buying food preparing food and
cleaning food I'm not even to get into
the 4 hours a day that the average
person spends on social media and
watching television you're going to keep
doing that so I'm not even going to try
convince you not to but if you just
replace those things that you probably
don't want to do it cost about $1,500
per month and so as long as you make
more than $15 per hour because it cost
about 96 hours to replace those
activities which means if I can replace
96 hours of work for $1,500 and it's
also 96 hours of draining work like it
expends energy it's not like you just
sit there for 96 hours you're actually
getting actively tired from doing that
stuff if you took that same thing and if
you make more than $15 per hour in your
active job it makes sense it's The
Logical decision for you to buy that and
then go make more cuz you're also going
to make money twice not only are you
going to save the time and then work and
make more but you also get better at
your job because all of those extra
hours aren't just making you more money
you're also becoming more skilled so you
get better faster and so if I have a
year-long guy where he spends $1,500 a
month to replace all of those things at
the end of that year not only does he
have more money at the end of the year
but because he had extra 100 hours of
high energy time that he didn't have to
spend per month he's getting 50% better
per year and so that assumes that he
doesn't get rewarded in his work for
getting better which by the way in
reality you typically do as long as you
ask who you compare yourself to not who
you spend your most time with will be
the highest predictor of how much you
make and so we are motivated by the
things that we lack and so if you are
very hungry it's because you lack food
if you lack sleep you're very tired
you're very motivated to sleep and so if
you want to be motivated to make money
it's not enough to not have money you
have to have a desire to make a lot more
money and the strongest way to create
that desire is to visually see the
people who are making far more than you
and so it's about who you compare
yourself to not who you spend time with
fundamentally the richest man in the
world only spends time with people
poorer than him but he continues to get
richer because he's comparing himself to
the the future version of himself that's
his reference point that's his reference
grip and when you start out there's real
people as you evolve it becomes
imaginary I heard this quote from one
person to another when I was walking
through the street and it was talking
about buying something that was a no a
no return investment let's call it a big
toy and he said there will always be
time to make money later and I remember
hearing that and
thinking that's what someone who's poor
says
and so to be clear I think if you want
to enjoy life by all means do it this
video is about making more money that's
the stated objective and so that's what
I'm talking about and so the idea that
you're going to spend now work later is
the fundamental Crux of
poverty and so you have to break that
with all your heart and when you have
those people around you and this was a
toy but it could be let's go out we it
always comes under the guise of YOLO we
have to live life but everyone who says
that assumes that getting better and
learning is not
life and is not living and for me the
purpose of my life is to learn as much
as I can and pay down ignorance as much
as I possibly can and squeeze the last
drop of potential out of me that I can
and the way that I do that is through
learning and so for every person that
asks you to sacrifice working now so
that you can have fun now just make sure
you know the trade you're making I'll be
real with you there's no perfect way to
live your 20s or even your 30s you
either end up an under skilled
30-year-old or 40-year-old or an
underlied 30-year-old or 40-year-old and
so fundamentally it's not either or but
knowing the trade-off and living with
the consequences because you can't do
them over and on a personal note I
sacrificed or said differently invested
my 20s in in order to have lots of
skills and
underlied but in that same time period I
built to where I am now and I genuinely
am very happy with where I am now in
life and I would not redo those years to
have quote lived more because the real
secret is as I was doing it I loved the
game and so some of the best moments of
my life when I look back were some of
the moments that I felt like I was
struggling the most because it was when
I underwent the most growth and so it's
interesting because the pain that you go
through in the moment often becomes the
purpose that you look back on in your
life and so the idea that we want to
avoid pain so that we can live today I
think conflates reality because when you
look back on your life a lot of times
those are the things that define you and
so we should be seeking those out not
running away from them so if you're not
sure who you compare yourself to versus
who you spend time with when you're
about to make a big decision the people
who come up in your mind who you're
weighing their opinions on your decision
those are your reference group people
the people whose opinion you care about
and so if all your friends for example
are billionaires and they all sacrific
their 20s got rid of their friends got
rid of their material belonging spent
all their time working for free so that
they could learn this big skill set and
then double down in their late 20s and
then made it big by the time they were
in their 30s and 40s those people if
that was your reference group if you're
thinking about leaving home what do you
think that reference group is going to
say for sure and because of that you're
out the door and so whenever you have
these moments where you are like I think
I should do this but whoever that person
is whoever that voice is if they don't
have what you want don't listen to what
they say only listen to other people's
opinions about your life if their dreams
for you are bigger than yours if they're
not disregard invest then spend the rest
so the idea is that you invest first and
then spend what's left over and so an
interesting thing is that Switzerland
has the highest per capita millionaires
in the world without having the highest
GDP or even GDP per capita and so how
are they able to do that that means that
they have different rules around money
which is what this video is about and so
if we adopt those rules we can get those
outcomes which means these are just
decisions that we get to make and the
easiest way to do that is you take what
you need off the top and then you spend
the rest on what you want and so it
comes down to saying that you need your
future you need your future self to be
bigger than your current self today and
so you invest first and then you spend
the rest and so the way that I like to
think about this is 16 this is how we
operationalize this which is automate
investing and then create friction
around spending and so you want to take
the money off before you see it if your
job for example has a way that they can
automatically skim off your paycheck and
put it into some sort of investment
stuff do it if they don't have that have
one of these apps that does segmentation
or has multiple bank accounts that you
can say this automatically goes here
this automatically goes here and and I
don't touch this and if you want to get
real crazy the advanced version of this
is that as you make more money you keep
what you're living the spend the rest
part instead of making it a percentage
make it a fixed amount and then as you
make more you're just investing more and
more and more into the future now you're
like well how do I invest in the future
if I'm just starting out the future is
you but you're making sure that when
you're investing that money you know
whether you're buying declarative
knowledge or you're buying procedural
knowledge you're learning about stuff
that you need to learn or you're
learning how to do it and the longer you
do this the easier it gets for the
record I have zero Lamborghinis zero
Rolexes zero
Jets while also being able to buy
multiple of these every single month and
so the idea is you start to become
addicted to getting good and once you
get that first little reward of seeing
an investment that you made in yourself
start paying off you see your income go
up you start making more money you're
like oh my God this game is awesome and
so that flow of investment that comes to
you is one of the best games that you
want to win for yourself you want to
just keep seeing keep making cash flow
PRS keep making that investment account
PR and hit records in that account and
if you get addicted to that game if you
can just do that from everything in this
video you've already won and so you want
to automate deposits and manualized
withdrawals so everything that is
automatic in terms like your rent you
want to write it as a check if you or
drop it off as cash if you have payments
that you make like a car payment as much
as you're like wait this is going to
cost time the value that you get back
for knowing exactly where you spend your
money is going to make you more money
than the one hour a month that you have
to pay your bills that is a promise and
so that may also mean if you make it
difficult to buy well then maybe you
delete some of the apps on your phone
maybe you don't save your credit cards
on the sites that you tend to spend
money on you want to make it as hard as
you can to spend money and make it as
easy as possible to stack it number 17
it's easier to make a million dollar
than it is to make $100,000 and let me
explain if I told you to go down the
block you would go at a certain speed if
I said go as fast as you possibly can at
some point you'd run and then you'd
improve your form and you get better
Footwear and then You' change your
clothes but at some point you wouldn't
be able to run any harder or any faster
to get there but if I said I need you to
go five blocks you might be like huh
okay now some people will then try to
walk or run that but the Smart Cookie
then says huh I could take a car and I
would go a hell of a lot faster and if
I'm speeding in my car I'll probably get
to the fifth block before the other guy
gets to the end of the first block and
so the magic of thinking bigger is that
you change your solution said meaning
you use different tools to accomplish
the objective the reason $100,000 per
year is the hardest amount of money to
make is because it assumes for most
people that they will trade their time
in terms of hourly wages or salary and
traditional work in order to get it and
so they have to spend all of their time
in order to make
$100,000 but if I said make a million or
even 10 million before the world
explodes you would know that you would
have to use a different way of solving
that problem and so the reason it's easy
I to make a million doll or $10 million
is because you can do it in less time
with more
skill if you start solving for the
skills required to make a million or $10
million you don't want to love money you
want to learn to love making money so
there's two misconceptions and then one
truth around this the first
misconception is money is the root of
all evil and then that obviously is a
quote from the Bible 1 Timothy 6:10 the
2011 version someone says no it's not
money that's the root of all evil it's
the love of money that's the root of all
evil but that's just the 2011 version
the actual translation there's five
translations for it and four of the five
are the love of money is the root of all
kinds of evil meaning if you desire
money more than anything else then you
will commit the other sins in order to
attain it
and so the idea is that it's only a
pathway that has a high likelihood of
causing you to do things that are
unethical or immoral and so there's this
huge terrible Paradigm in society that
money is somehow good or bad it is just
potential energy it's just bottled time
and that bottled time can build bombs
that bottled time can build hospitals it
can build Wells and can build schools it
can make YouTube videos that educate and
so the idea that you're afraid to make
money means that you're afraid of having
power and maybe you should be afraid of
having power because maybe you'd misuse
it but if you do want to help the world
then all it's going to do is amplify
your ability to do that and if you have
that mission on your heart or in your
mind then it's your duty to remove
everything else in your [__] way to
go get it the more money you make other
people the more money you make and so
the amount of money that you will be
able to make in your career comes down
to three variables number one is the
value that you're able to create in
total for all of the people you create
it for times your ability to negotiate
how much of that value you're able to
get times number three which is the
amount of other people who can also
create that value and you have to have
all three because for example if you
develop a skill of sales and you can
create millions of dollars in value for
a company and you're really good at
negotiating then in theory you'd get
millions and millions of dollars from
that company but if somebody else is
willing to work for a few $1,000 a year
in order to make that value then your
position disappears and so that gives us
the blueprint for making money is that
not only do you want to be able to
create that value you want to be able to
create a value in a way that no one else
can and the way that you do that is not
by in my opinion learning some
incredibly secret unique skill what
makes skills unique is the skill set
it's the stack of skills together that
create the uniqueness if someone else
has to try and recreate something I
could do they would have to have lived
my life and so your life and the time
you spend becomes your competitive
Advantage it becomes your asset it
becomes the moat that other people can't
chip into they'd have to go through
being a competitive Fitness person and
then go through owning lots of gyms and
then go through doing turnarounds across
the country and then go through doing a
licensing business and then go through
making a supplement business and then go
through launching a meal prep business
and then also starting a software
company and then going through an exit
for both and then starting a private
they'd have to do so much stuff there
are so many skills that are required
your time is your weapon if you invest
it wisely and the one thing that I would
leave you with is that money loves speed
wealth loves time poverty loves
indecision if this stuff was valuable
for you and hopefully it helps you avoid
losing all your money twice like I did
uh I have a video on Leverage and wealth
creation that you can check out it's I
think the number one video on this
channel and it's one of the fastest ways
to compound wealth if you poor and
you're just getting started or just want
to start in a business I have brutally
honest advice to my younger self that a
lot of people seem to have really found
value in